the miracles of modern technology what I
have to travel with me basis and the
piece of paper well it's not bad okay so
this should be pretty painless I hope
and all right yeah 15 questions 15
questions all right solid the final on
making up the whole so I'll start with
my favorite Oh what did you want to be
when or where did you grow up I guess I
wrote in Philadelphia Pennsylvania until
I was in my I guess mid 20s or so I'm
growing up what did you want to be oh
well I started out I'm gonna side with
the usual childhood pensive cowboy a
fireman etc etc I started out my first
interest were in science I thought
astronomy I wanted to be an astronomer
and that lasted through the middle of
high school when I got involved with the
with the drama club there and then I
became interested in the theater I think
it's much because I went to an all-boys
school and there was an all-girls school
down the street and the only interaction
between the two of them was within the
theater group because we need girls to
play some of the roles so that seemed
like seemed like a good idea at the time
so I summer what have they got involved
with the theater and then state with
that actually I did not go to not go
into science until a rather late in life
in fact so I worked in the theater for a
number of years 15 almost 20 years out
of high school i apprenticed myself to
various people I never really went to
college for it in those days you didn't
you kind of worked as an apprentice and
you worked your way up through this to
that and I eventually my goal there was
to order to be a director so I did a
little bit of acting but very little but
mostly stage managing lighting design
that kind of thing and then eventually
directing which I did for a number of
years both on the East Coast mostly in
rep companies and on the west coast in
San Francisco a little bit
los angeles and then one day I decided
to go back to school however you've
learned on 30 years old for no
particular reason I got involved with a
show that seemed like it was going to
run for a while I've done the lighting I
was asked to stay on and run the
lighting so I did it looked like it was
going to be a job for a while at night I
always had this interest now not so much
an astronomy when I developed an
interest in animal behavior particular
and in those days one could go to San
Francisco State University in a
California State University system was
one of the great marvels of the
educational world one could go there and
be a full-time student for I think it
was a hundred and six dollars a semester
and that's not so long ago I mean even
though I look like it should have been a
long time ago was not so long ago it was
in nineteen whether I start their 1983
so you know 27 years ago but even in
today's dollars how much would that be
you know so one hundred and six dollars
want to go be a full-time student I did
not in fact go to be a full-time student
I went it took one class in animal
communication from a professor in hell
Markowitz who has remained to this day a
good friend and he was a wonderful
mentor maybe the most important thing
that happened to me and my wife are all
the way through and I just had a
wonderful time taking this class I
thought well this is really common I've
never been to college or even so I
thought this is really cool somehow this
guy stands up there tells you everything
he knows about something I side the
who thought of this I guess it was our
style of in fact someone like that but
but that was the idea you know and I
thought well that this is really great I
and I enjoyed the class and I got to be
sort of friendly with with how it was
only like 10 years older than me in fact
maybe 15 and then he convinced me to
take another class that he was teaching
also an animal
behavior which I did and I enjoyed and
then he somehow or another I can't
actually recollect to this day how he
did it kind of buttered me up and said
well you know you're good at this you
should take a classes you take a degree
in biology and you could do research
with me I think that was his idea that I
would do research with him so I did and
I somehow or another sort of taking
classes in biology and that's what I did
for the next three or four years and I
wound up with an undergraduate degree in
biology which is we all now know is
completely worthless really so terrible
thing maybe that should be okay okay
well it's worthless in the sense that I
think what it really sets you up it's
one of those degrees one of those
undergraduate degrees like most science
degrees are that really sets you up to
go on to do postgraduate work so a
little old for medical school and really
wasn't all that interested in medicine
or sick people or any of that kind of
stuff but I did like research and so I
thought well graduate school I guess so
so this really was a choice point for me
I suppose I i thought well i can either
i was can I continue to work in the
theater all this time although at a more
minimal level because I was it was kind
of odd I was a full-time day student
worked at night i'm usually here a
full-time you know workers who take
classes at night I took classes of the
day and worked at night it was kind of
an odd reversal but but I don't know a
lot just I could just go back and you
know and you're my work in the theater I
was reasonably successful and do that
with my undergraduate degree in biology
for whatever it has been fun and
interesting or I could go to graduate
school and try a new career and see what
happened I was 35 years old so for I
don't what the hell I'll apply to
graduate school and see what happens so
I applied to several graduate schools
are going to do a couple most notably I
got into UC Berkeley I think largely is
the result of a clerical error commonly
say but I didn't care i said yes
immediately and that's where i went and
met another great professor another
mentor from Nathan and Frank werblin who
worked in the visual system there in
neuroscience and I hooked up with his
lab he kind of got me and got to be
friends and he got me into his lab
that's where I did my graduate work and
he was just a wonderful tremendous
mention we also are very good friends he
was sitting on that sofa right there
last week that last Wednesday I guess
first anyway he's in town so he came
over to visit and we stay in touch
pretty regularly so I finished a
graduate degree there by my 40th
birthday which was my idea I was hoping
that you know somehow or another I could
get through this career in time that
there could be a couple of years between
10 urine and emeritus you know to try to
enjoy this a bit so so I did that and
then I wound up getting a very nice
postdoctoral position at Yale University
yellow med school with another great
mentor a fella named Gordon Shepherd who
really had a great deal of great
influence on the rest of my life I was a
postdoc there and then he pushed me
because I was older I think at least
partly pushed me very quickly into an
assistant professor position so he got
me on to the faculty and we got grants
together and things like that and that's
really what kind of started my career I
suppose and I stayed there for about
five years old at all and still very
close with Gordon Gordon may be the most
because we work in the same field of
course he's also works in the sense of
smell and all that so so we continue to
collaborate on some things and so forth
so I was I must say I was very lucky
because I had three really exceptional
mentors and I often wonder i must say
because you know i hear these horror
stories from graduate students or post
office about these awful mentors quote
that they work with these p is as we
call the principal investigators who run
the labs that they work in and you know
steal this from the one treat them like
or don't give them credit where
they deserve I don't know hundreds of
different things and you just hear these
complaints I'm it's not that widespread
but you hear it a remarkable amount and
I think to myself I just get lucky but I
got lucky three times I don't I don't
really know but but it for me I have to
say it brought home to be the importance
of the whole mentoring relationship
which we you know we don't teach anybody
I mean I got taught how to be a
scientist like I taught a lot of facts
as an undergraduate I got taught how to
do experiments as a graduate student I
got taught sort of how to publish papers
and get grants and do more experiments
and think a little more deeply as a
postdoc but nobody ever really taught me
how to run a laboratory how to have
students how to have postdocs how to
mentor people in a way I mean I learned
it I think decently because I had three
tremendous examples in my own life but
but even those people i just took by
example I mean nobody ever said to me
well this is how you do this and I guess
I don't really say it exactly the
students or post docs in my laboratory
because I don't know unfortunately but
it's a critical thing that we really
somehow don't think about as much as we
probably ought to in my opinion so that
was one of the reasons I came to
Columbia it was a sort of an off thing
there was a sort of a job open here but
not exactly when I came down and gave a
talk to the department and they liked me
and I liked them and we worked it out
and I at Yale I was at the Medical
School which is a common place for
biologists to be even if you're not a
doctor a lot of research labs there and
I could have stated a medical stayed at
Yale for that matter which was a very
good place or I could have taken jobs
and a variety of medical schools that I
wanted to go on to something else but I
always really wanted to return to a
university situation what did graduate
school Berkeley which is a university
not a medical school
situation and the medical school was
great it's very intense it's very
focused there's lots of people there to
talk to and scientists and all sorts of
things and it's a great place to start a
career but it just was not I couldn't
see spending my life in a medical school
which is to institute like somehow or
another and I liked undergraduates and I
like teaching and and I somehow or other
is going to sound terribly corny you
know feel a certain responsibility to
return what I was given and I think I
have a better chance of doing that or an
undergraduate sort of campus University
campus plus I like hanging out with
philosophers and classicists and
language people they think completely
different than we and the science is
doing it's interesting to be on
committees with them to tell you the
truth so alright so that was way too
long yeah you insert if you have one of
team the westerbeck no actually answer
960 okay that's a good thing and I said
how you ended up at Columbia did you I
mean when you applied to columbia where
was it the university was the city i
mean was it was mainly the idea of being
teaching position being the university
yeah well no I mean I you know this this
department the biology department here
is dedicated to research virtually every
member of this department runs a fairly
sizable full-time laboratory operation
with a minute varies a lot some people
like small lab some people like big labs
some people's research is better suited
to a small lab just a few students some
people do the kind of research that
really you need a kind of an army of
people we don't do so much of the army
of people stuff here but but we have
labs that have anywhere from two or
three grad students in a postdoc 2567
graduate students and five or six
postdocs I'm about in the middle so at
different times my laboratory has been
as big as 12 or 14 people it's been as
small as just two or three when I first
got started but and now it's at about
eight or nine something like that so one
laboratories here I mean this is a nice
thing about Columbia the great charm of
this place
seems to me is it's a major research
institution that nonetheless finds a way
to run is over a small liberal arts
college and that's really a remarkable
combination of things that you don't
often find so you know most students are
faced with this choice I'll go to small
liberal arts college and get this
well-rounded wonderful education with a
lot of a lot of attention from
professors and all that but there's no
professional level work going on there
that in that sense or you go to some
major research institution you know
university of michigan or but you know
all these kinds of places and but there
you lose the you know you're in 35,000
students or something like that and be
classrooms to are largely by graduate
students often or things like that and
here i think you get really you get both
of those things i have to say the
humanities i'll have to be honest seem
to be at the moment or successful about
that than the sciences are but i think
we're coming along with that I think
frontiers of science is if it's not a
perfect course yet the idea of the
science is adding to the core is a
critical new development here and it's
just it's so important as a new way of
thinking that whether or not the class
works perfect items like critique about
the class and it's a work in progress
but even if it doesn't work perfectly
yet it will eventually and the idea of
including it in the court as a sea
change for size can you expand it and
you've worked you've been part of that
getting fringes of silence and can you
expand that I mean where you see it
going and how you see it yeah it's a
good question of it's very difficult
it's up for about five year review now
so it sits in its fifth year I mean I
have to say I did not do I don't want to
take any credit for getting it started
or anything like that the heavy lifting
was done primarily by Darcy Kelly and
David halfa and a bit by Don hood I mean
people
who had members of senior members on
what they make it sound like they're
ancient but senior members of our
faculty have been at Columbia for many
years and who knew precisely what the
shortcomings were and what the what the
what the real love what the greatness of
the university was built on and the fact
that science wasn't fully participating
in that and so that so they had this was
real motivation to do that and I a
tremendous amount of credit goes to them
for that because they pulled this course
together largely out of nothing I mean
they created a you know from zero I know
they had long discussions over it i know
some of them i was in a couple of them
but whatever what the form should take
and what it shouldn't take and now i've
taught in it for a few years and now
it's sort of our view and i'm actually
on the committee on instruction so one
of these will do is review it and it's
it's not a trivial issue exactly how to
work it i mean i think there are parts
of it that work and there are parts of
it that don't work the parts of it the
work seem to be the big lecture things
where you get Columbia's world-renowned
faculty or some members of it to come
and put together these three or four two
three four lectures in their field but
making their field accessible and I
think that alone aside from what it may
do for the students which of course is
still the primary thing but that alone
is I think an important thing because
you actually enlist faculty who usually
spend all their time varying in the lab
and buried in their field and worried
about the next paper of the next grant
and all the rest of this and the
competition you get them to take a pause
and think about how to put their work
out there for mostly lay audience a
group of smart kids but not trained not
in any way prepared and just the
exercise of doing that I think is for
many of us and very important and will
make people who have done it very useful
when the university is called upon to
have a spokesperson for this or that I
mean we're in New York where the media
and that's what happens some scientific
thing happens and press office here
should get a call from some journalists
or another a writer and say who's google
I who's the expert at Columbia and we'll
have an expert as we build this group up
we'll have experts who know how to talk
to the to the public about what's going
on what they're doing i which i think is
a critical issue so in that sense I
think the course has been very
successful I think it's been good for
the students to see the kind of depth it
that researching goes on in Columbia you
know the way at them the way it happens
here and then the depth of it and the
breadth of it and the people that are
involved a little less successful as I
understand that from the student reports
are the sort of individual meetings the
classes that meet once a week for two
hours and smaller group so the lectures
are given the groups of five hundred
students so what you can do with that
and then the ideas that they meet and do
activities or discussions or this or
that based on the lectures themselves
and that seems to at the moment be the
weak part of the course its weak on
several accounts i think it's also the
most labor-intensive it's the most
difficult for the course organizers to
get organized to enlist all the people
to do it uses up a lot of faculty and so
it's the part of the course that uses
the most resources but as may be and
therefore has to give out impact the
most i think but is probably not doing
that at the moment so i think i will
figure out how to fix that eventually i
don't know how i don't know how okay to
tell you the truth i mean there are a
lot of ideas around i have some ideas
and and the nice thing about Darcy Kelly
and Damien halfan the real now the cove
for runners of the course I guess
Donovan a little bit too is that they're
very open to this I mean it's their baby
and you know and I wouldn't blame them
for being incredibly defensive but in
fact they're not there they seem pretty
into it so I think things will happen I
think it's taken five years to figure
out where that where you want to improve
it without throwing the whole the baby
out with the bathwater is their state
what are you working on right now ah so
my laboratory works on the sense of
smell they were neuroscience laboratory
so our interest is the brain and how it
works and that's the big question of
course no hope of answering that
whatsoever we've decided to hive off a
smaller piece of it and the smaller
piece that I came away with was the nose
which is either all over the place here
is trouble with working on the nose is
you get yeah everybody thinks so there's
a great gift for snow let's get him a
nose as if I don't have it you know so
this is the best of the list of paper
weight and this is actually a model that
was made for sculpting students it's a
model of Michelangelo's David of the
nose from Michelangelo's David because
it's considered the most perfect version
of it and so art students are supposed
to copy it was a paperweight but that's
our anyway so we use the nose as most
scientists do as what we call a model
system so this is a sort of a critical
idea in science that I think I must say
the public and even many students don't
really understand well and it gives rise
to unfortunately a lot of
misunderstandings between the public and
science so the brain is just too hard to
understand all by itself you know just
sit there and look at it and try to
figure out how it works this is really
difficult so one looks for simpler
systems along the idea that fundamental
mechanisms in the brain are going to be
found even at simpler levels either it's
simpler organisms like worms or flies
flies have a long history here at
Columbia the whole fruit fly genetics
revolution started here in scrum or horn
hall at Columbia with Thomas Hunt Morgan
for now just 100 years ago and that was
the beginning of genetics I mean in
genetics is still a pretty big field and
it all sort of with fruit flies and
indeed there's still thousands of people
to work on fruit fly genetics which we
continue to learn a great deal because
it turns out that a lot of fruit fly
jeans we actually have them to you know
I mean they have legs they have heads
you know I understand that wings and we
don't but birds have wings you know and
it takes genes to make all those things
and oddly enough it takes many of the
same genes so anyway so it's true when
you work on simpler organisms to more
complicated ones and that we all believe
because we all believe in evolution and
so there's a continuity in life and
therefore even though we have a bigger
brain we have a hundred billion brain
cells each one of those brain cells is
not so very different from the 302 brain
cells that you find in a little tiny
nematode worm that many people work on
so they only have three hundred and we
have a hundred billion well that's a big
difference I agree and there's some
things that you can't say it's this way
the worms dissuade us but the neurons
themselves those three hundred neurons
are not so different from the hundred
billion that we have which have a lot
more of them and they connect up a lot
more so you can study simpler organisms
to learn about more complicated
organisms or you can study subsystems of
complicated organisms so a mouse is
pretty complicated maybe that's
complicated as a human but a sense of
smell probably is and we think it's a
good organized a good the sense of smell
is a good sub system of the brain to
learn a lot about important issues in
the brain I would give you two or three
examples if you want so one of the
things that we study in a sense of smell
of course is what we would call
molecular recognition this thing here is
the best chemical detector on the face
of the planet it's no question about it
we even we humans supposedly don't have
such a great census
we do have better than we think biggest
problem with our sense of smells we walk
on two legs and all the good odors are
down there on the ground you know
they're heavy molecules they sink down
there and so we just don't get our noses
where the owners are you know other
animals walk on four legs noses are
right on the ground where they put their
noses where they where the owners are
which we also don't do I'm very happy
about also but but if we did put our
nose right where the owners were we'd
smell them believe me anyway but it is
still a great detector of chemicals
these chemicals that are odors there are
hundreds of thousands of them and
they're just small molecules that float
around and given off by plants or foods
or things like that or other other
organisms fire all kinds of things but
they're all small molecules and these
small molecules don't look so different
to tell you the truth biochemically from
molecules like dopamine or serotonin or
acetylcholine very important
neurotransmitters and hormones and
things like that and it turns out that
the receptors that we use the proteins
that we use to recognize molecules like
dopamine and serotonin and our brains
are very very closely related to the
receptors that our nose produces in
order to smell the world out there and
so understanding molecular recognition
can help us to understand how drugs can
be produced how we can design drugs how
how serotonin works with serotonin
receptors because some odor like I don't
know amyl acetate that smells like
bananas works a certain way with banana
type receptors and the molecules they
look so different so this whole idea of
molecular recognition what are the
principles of how organism how
biological organism recognizes molecules
either internally or externally that's
one area olfactory neurons thus the
cells that make up the olfactory part of
the brain are unique among neurons and
that their renewable you get you make
new ones your whole life don't you have
any other neuron no other neuronal
population is replaced in an adult once
you're born you about all the neurons
you're ever going to get but you lose a
lot of them during development and then
you lose a lot more as you get older of
course and so and due to injury or
pathology or whatever you may lose
significant numbers in neurons we have
no way of replacing them the olfactory
system replaces them and so if we could
learn about how this happens and we're
studying is one of those we work on my
laboratory so there are two important
questions there one is how do you make
new neurons so there are stem cells stem
cells a big word now there's usual
operas in this case there are these are
not the stem cells of embryonic stem
cells which could turn into anything
these are neural stem cells the only
thing they can become as neurons and at
the moment the only link it becomes
olfactory neurons but nonetheless they
sit there in the brain and continue to
divide and make noon olfactory neurons
so one thing we could know is how do
they do that and could we reprogram them
to make a different kind of neurons
saying neuron that that squirted out
dopamine and could be used to replace
the neurons we lose in Parkinson's
disease and that would perhaps cure
Parkinson's so how do they proliferate
how do they proliferate and most
importantly is how do they integrate
into an already mature brain so that
what smells to you like a rose today
doesn't smell like a seeping pile of
garbage to you the next day right that
mean you have that will come so well yet
your factory system does this it makes
30,000 new cells a day which is a big
chunk of cells and yet those cells
integrate into an existing it was
happening in you and me right now and
they integrate into an existing brain
that's already learned things and thumb
things in a setup and and I figure out
how to do this and that's critical
because it doesn't do any good to just
figure out how to make neuro because you
can't just make a big dish full of
neurons and shove them into someone's
brain and hope for the best you know
they have to get into the right place
you can't just take a Cell Stem Cell
that wants to divide and become neuron
just stick in someone's brain you're
just going to tumor you know that won't
do you any good so you have to figure
out how to make new cells and how
integrate them into an existing mature
brain and I think the olfactory system
at least is one place to bring where
that goes on every day of our lives so
it's great system for trying to figure
them so there's just two of about half a
dozen or more questions and I think we
can get to withhold faction fascinating
look at this yeah not to mention that
it's all about food and wine and sexist
asshole to you know what are you
teaching next semester next semester
most of the teaching I do is actually
usually in the in the fall semester
where I teach this big dreadful cell and
molecular neurobiology course it really
sounds very scary i mean i don't think
of couldn't make it sound any more old
testament if we wanted to you can open
quickly that doesn't scare of all of
nothing will so bizarre just finished
teaching that course it's a it's a not
basic it's a very sophisticated but
introduction to the brain kind of course
for undergraduate for a typically a
biology major or in neuroscience major
and that's my main teaching
responsibilities here is that course and
i teach a couple of graduate seminars
but then over the last few years in the
spring i've been teaching a course that
I sort of kind of slapped together
myself in a way just because it's
something I've been interested in and
its course called ignorance and it's
particularly interesting I have to say
it it comes out of this notion that that
the one mistake that we make unavoidably
but we make this mistake in teaching
science especially undergraduates is
that we just teach them a lot of facts
fill them up with facts and and that's
not trivial it's not the facts are
important they are and at some staging
to develop as a scientist it's important
to get all these facts down I mean or
some bunch of them and so that's
unavoidable but it's not what science is
about when I go to a meeting or
hang out in the lab or you know beat up
with a scientist pal at a bar or
whatever we never talked about what we
know we only talk about what we don't
know it's the only thing that's of any
interest to a scientist is what they
don't know but I was worried that we
weren't giving our students any sense of
that at all that they just thought
science was some big old fact book and
if you just could memorize it that would
be fine just one sec hi can I call you
back in just about five or ten minutes
okay bye so I thought well maybe to be
interesting to try and I sort of worked
it into my home course a little but I
would my last lecture I would talk about
okay now fill you up with all these
facts about cell and molecular
neuroscience may seem like we know
everything is big thick textbook but
look really i'm just going to throw out
dozens of questions and tell you we
don't any of these things you know
here's all the stuff we have no idea
about and it's a lot more than what we
know that's important because I mean
there's work for you there's a future in
this you know so then I started thought
I thought about maybe we could expand in
this course even made expand descent
into a course and so the course
basically is I only teach it in the
spring and it's only limitation as it's
only excuse me solely for seniors I do
that for two reasons why is it's a sort
of a capstone kind of equality and the
other major reason is that I don't
really want to deal with grades and for
the most part seniors you know you can't
affect your GPA by very much one way or
the other with one course of this matter
of a grade they really get and by their
last semester most of them are already
in graduate school or medical school or
law school because whatever it is
they're going you know from here they're
already got that sort of setup and so
the grades just don't matter as much and
so I don't have to worry about the great
things it's just done up for me so it's
typically a small course a little over
limited but somewhere between 30 and 50
students and we meet once a week from
six to eight pm typically on Wednesday
nights and I invite most of the course
we meet once a week since about 13 or 14
meetings per semester and for about
eight of them eight or nine of them I
invite members of the faculty the
science faculty from various departments
to come in one at a time and spend two
hours with the students and tell them
all about what they don't know and just
talk to them about what it is they don't
know what they want to know why they're
working on this and not that how they
came to this question why this is a
critical question when it's more
important than that one what will happen
if you don't know this what will happen
if we do know it etc at center all those
sorts of things and so it's great it's
always a little bit funny and I call
people up on the phone I say hi so and
so listen up teaching this course of
ignorance and I think you'd be great you
know so it's always a tricky sort of an
invitation but but the great thing is
the faculty you're all realized
immediately that that's absolutely right
of course I know that that's what I
really could talk you know and usually
that's what I get out finally something
I get something I can talk about
intelligently so and that's what they do
no power points no you know very little
preparation just come in and let's
discuss what you don't know and it's
been great so I have chemists physicists
mathematicians biologists neurobiologist
microbiologist climate people walk
engineers all kinds of of coming over
this would be the fourth year and I
think it's been very successful students
seem to like it a great deal they get
into it and and it's fascinating and I
learned a lot about what the other
faculty around here doing and it's very
interesting because you take up so so
mathematics was always done you know the
tricky one I thought I going to be able
to get math down here are they gonna be
able to say anything that anybody can
understand to anybody but ten other
people in the world you know that's and
they think that way most mathematicians
you go to them and they say
nobody understands what ice is only ten
colleagues I have it understand but it
turns out that they they do do a good
job so I tried a couple and they're
pretty good at it oddly enough in fact
they're dying for somebody to understand
what it is they do they're sick of
talking to the same 10 people you know
and that's true of a lot of science
we've got broke balkanized in science
and overly specialized the nice thing
about talking about what you don't know
is you tend not to use a lot of jargon
and you tend not to make a lot of
assumptions about What's in people's
heads already like you do say with
colleagues or something when you know so
so that's the nice thing about it is it
makes it much more accessible to
students so many of the students aren't
science majors I don't make that a
requirement there's no science
prerequisite for the course I'd say
about a third of the students are either
not science majors or their science
majors and some humanities made a double
major in there you manage to so I have a
lot of people from classics literature
religion philosophy etc etc in there as
well it has been very interesting it's
been a great core section my favorite
thing to do here alright let's get into
it okay later question okay where do you
live in the Columbia ghetto here
Columbia housing so or could have an
apartment on Riverside Drive which the
university is nice enough to rent to me
at a reasonable rate I think that's a
great idea though not to get off on
another long tension here but now the
housing situation of Columbia is one of
its key resources I believe and I
sometimes think it doesn't treat it that
way I mean I know everybody thinks it's
important because we all clamor over and
all that but the difference between
Columbia here in quote Morningside
Heights which is we all know is really
Harlem at Yale University in New Haven
which is also very depressed kind of an
area it's just night and day y'all never
made that kind of advice
in the community they did not buy
property in the community they do not
induce people to live in New Haven and
indeed everybody lives in the suburbs
and it's pitiful because here's this
great University in a town that should
be able to add to its economy and had to
look to the quality of life of all the
residents there by having the university
sort of in mesh tin the community and
stop I mean yale university is
surrounded by parking lots which the
faculty pulled into from the suburbs in
the morning and they pulled out at night
you know and the students stay in these
colleges these residential colleges
which are very inward looking at all of
courtyards and that's going to do this
is so much more lively and so much more
interesting I mean you have you have a
kind of like a little university town in
the middle of Manhattan here you know
and it's kept this neighborhood vibrant
it's why I frankly I'm a supporter of
manhattanville I actually do kind of
supportive manhattanville for weird
reasons unlike president Bollinger who
feels the Manhattan knows the solution
to a space problem I don't really feel
we have a space problem in Columbia I
really like being cramped together
that's a new york thing maybe or
whatever but i like that they have been
cheek by jowl and not having you know
having so little space we have to think
carefully about what we do with it and
make collaborations with each other to
use our space better and things like
that so I'm all for that what I like
about manhattanville is and I think it
will be a great improvement to that
neighborhood up there and it needs it
you know and I think it will make and
either going to be a gateway into Harlem
and annalynne to grade Colombian of a
Harlem neighborhood and make it more
vibrant and that will I think urban
planning point of view universities in
my opinion make good neighbors not
everybody thinks that you see your
glasses where'd you find them in the
cart the vaccination year looking for
those for three weeks I actually went
bought a new pair haha finalized good
now I have a spare pair they ask our
addresses thanks how are you yeah well
there's the old bumbling professor thing
and you've got it with everywhere
thank you very much and now you've got
it on film too there you go it's typical
so so I think the whole neighborhood
thing here is very important the fact
that we that the faculty live here staff
with your students live here and it
becomes vibrant nature so what I like
living in the city anyway that's part of
the great attraction so you mentioned
you've gotten to Uganda value through
animal behavior gently pets well yes did
I'm afraid I saw sorry how that's a pen
here have one I have just never ever
have one cat now but had a big old
Newfoundland until about a year ago he
passed away a year ago and we have not
quote we placed him of course he's
irreplaceable but but my daughter who
just turned 18 is now college student
here i'm happy to say so she moved out
of the house and that has made it I
think it's given us thoughts about
whether it get a pattern artists my wife
works with animals she's at hunter
college professor hunter and actually
does work in animal behavior which I
don't do so much anymore but she works
with big animals like dolphins and
elephants and things like that and she
really loves to have dogs and cats and
things around so but we thought twice
about a doctor's because neither of us
are really around as much and without a
kid there who's around some of the time
to pay attention dog I don't think a dog
gets enough attention you know so we
refrain for that but a one time we had a
dog two cats hamster all together all is
your daughter your only child yes and
she in the college or she's in the
college you guys just started that yes
yeah it's great it's great and she loves
it which is very nice because you know
as a faculty member you tend to sit on a
lot of committees that bitch and moan
and whine about how awful things are and
how we're going to fix them and why we
don't have enough resources for this and
that we're always complaining to
somebody as part of the deal apparently
you know and so you can get a very
warped view of the university so it's
really quite a pleasure to have her here
because I talk to her at least once a
week or so
each other and she just is having the
time of her life here she thinks its
greatest place on the planet I don't
think I well that that's good because I
had no idea you know as we gonna think
this is a dump here we're running some
kind of a I don't know what but it's not
the case it seems to be a pretty good
place for the students which is very
important how do you recharge it's a
good question heavy drinking stuff like
that well so it's a good question I I
don't know that that's not entirely
maybe I shouldn't say that I do like I
do actually like to hang out in coffee
shops or bars and have friends who are
not in the sciences and even some who
are not in academia part of who are I
still know some actors singers and
people like that and I think it's useful
to hang out with them because I kind of
you know so I hang out just by being
social i mean i recharged by being
social life that's good for me i'm happy
that yeah i bet we go up to the country
we have this such place in the country
we go up there for a couple days but you
know the odd little eerie charges me in
the sense it after about two days in the
country i get patient that I have to
come back and go to work again I get a
little buzz here from the city you know
dude your favorite spot in New York City
Oh a favorite spot in New York City
that's a good question I don't know I
like a lot of it i'm a walker so I like
to walk it's a great town to walking of
course so I mean I often I try to go out
for lunch every day you know I make sure
that the lab has no coffee machines in
it no microwaves no refrigerators
because I think it's actually important
not only for me but for the students to
get out as well they're not get in that
habit of eating three meals a day you
know in the hallway here going right
back to experiment I think they should
get out known to get for a cup of coffee
or for biting so I try and get out a
couple days a week at least four
can take a long walk either get on the
subway and go somewhere else almost
randomly and then have a bite to eat and
walk you know a mile or two back or a
mile or two and get back on the subway
so I don't know about a favorite place
in New York I'm trying to think of it I
mean I really love the city so I don't I
can't think of a particular it do you
Saudi still go to the theater do you
have a favorite play that you see
recently yeah wait I do still go to the
theater I um I go to other things more
than the theater I tend to go to the
symphony more than the theater I tend to
go to the Opera even more than the
theater but I do go to the theater
occasionally in fact I just went to
three pieces I guess you'd call them
sort of theater pieces new wave they
call this I guess are all about guard
pieces and I went to them as an emissary
of science magazine who asked me to
write a review on them so in fact I just
finished the galleys the proofs of this
review we should come out next week so
and I what the three things were really
spectacular I'll have to say so I was
lucky that way I went to a while Richard
Foreman's new piece called idiot savants
or Richard Foreman's is very avant-garde
director who's been around for 40 years
it's hard to believe because I remember
what he sort of first started can't
imagine that but but he's been doing
kind of wacko really you know minimal
now who'd called minimalist but what I
call this theater I don't know what to
call him he runs a company called the
ontological historical figures that'll
tell you what it is anyway did a piece
called idiot savant which maybe had a
little bit of a science he think about
it or something not really much but it's
very jesting with Willem Dafoe and that
in the so-called title role like SSI or
all but that was quite intriguing that
was at the public theater and then I saw
two pieces at bam the brooklyn academy
of music they were part of this new wave
festival one was a circus called intend
it's called circus or core but the piece
they did was called inside out the idea
being they took the inside of the body
and brought it out and and made a circus
event out of it it's very hard to
explain
short way but it was very intriguing a
little bit of a Cirque de Soleil kind of
thing but but a bit more intellectual as
well but no less fun and then finally
the best piece I've seen in a while I
guess was it was a concert performance
with nonetheless still spectacular of
philip glass's opera called Kepler which
is about the life and works of Kepler
sorry we're out no it's not anyway that
was really good i was also a band but
great theater pieces if I seen lately
did go to something that I really liked
and I can't think of what it was it's
really awful I want to see God of
Carnage ill actually didn't I just think
it's wildly overrated it's not bad but
it's wildly overrated it's the kind of
peace that in the hands of 0 of a Harold
Pinter or somebody like that would
really have been spectacular but I
wasn't in the hands of a Harold Pinter
it was a little bit somehow or another
you know wasn't quite Neil Simon and it
wasn't quite how interest in the middle
of those two things and I think it
really did anything much so but that was
me apparently it's flames of standing
room only crowd so what can I tell you
it was another theater piece I saw
recently this is terrible and I can't
run water water that we really enjoyed
immensely
a couple more yay uh here's dump on
what's your favorite food oh my favorite
food wow I don't know a lot of um
someone who studies in the news I yeah
yeah yeah so that's you know my favorite
well I mean you know living in New York
for somebody the Asian cuisine thing has
gotten so it so permeates everything
that I guess in many ways I live with
the guy use much Chinese food is a unit
charge thank it was that I have a
good friend who happens to be an Italian
chef who makes the best lasagna the
world though so as a single dish I might
have to put his lasagna at the very very
top of the list but otherwise i'm pretty
much an omnivore i have to say you know
i leave almost almost anything I mean
pulsating crawling things there's
nothing like that so much like it dead
but but otherwise I'm pretty I'm Liveris
everybody all right two more questions
that no time what's the last book you
read for pleasure that you really
enjoyed right I read a book called so
believe it or not I'm reading books
lately upon this um I got a Kindle a
while about and I actually don't like
the Kindle very much but it turns out
there's an app for the iphone for the
kindle and i love reading on this thing
is that weird actually I don't mind it
either i read the times on it now and
you know its a bright screen it's really
crisp and clear and gobbling is the
natural scrolling is very natural and
you know what's very nice about it also
is because of the because of the size of
it i tend to read much faster because i
read down a column instead of you know
all the way across the way they tell you
to chunk when you read but nobody can
ever really do that it's a few seven
types but this i feel i can actually
kind of go down a page so i'm just going
to go
Oh cure for a minute at the name so I
get the name of the book exactly right
the book I read was what I read was
there's a history book of all things
tried but crazy oh the vertigo years was
called by philipp lahm be LOM it's about
the time to history book about the time
fury between around 1919 15 and it's I
mean it's a different time than now but
there's certain similarities were
fascinating I'd say especially in
science but not entirely I'm lose the
age of electricity and dynamism dynamos
and all these new cars and things
like airplanes to some extent and and
radio and so forth and in the world I
mean they're people complained about how
fast the world was suddenly moving and
who could keep up with it all and all
the rest of that and you know it was a
very exciting time because it led some
good places in some bad places was very
fascinating to see how because you
couldn't help but think about our days
now through this as beautifully written
book beautifully written book so I
enjoyed that immensely that was I just
sort of picked that up for read a review
of it sounded do I read that and what on
your resume are you most proud of it's a
tough one I know
well I'd like to say but it's still a
work in progress really the list of
graduate students that have graduated
from my laboratory because mostly I
could say this paper or that paper this
fighting without fighting but it was
generally they're finding and in the end
I'll only be here for you know pitifully
short number of years but they'll be
here a lot more years and they'll have
students and one hopes it goes on that
way so for me really that greatest
pleasure is sort of watching this list
of graduate students and postdocs kind
of grow over the years and realize how
many people really kind of come through
and going on and done and are doing now
great thing to become colleague seems to
me that's our job our job here is to
grow colleagues you know I've said yeah
so if you do that you do that well then
you have good colleagues and you've done
your job and everything is right great
well thank you so much okay well I
really appreciate that
you